[Musique]
public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bruno retailleau le président du groupe
l'est républicain au sénat est l'invité
de l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir bonsoir
michel ancien et merci d'être avec nous
donc à ce rendez-vous de public sénat
avec les échos radio classique et la fp
vous répondrez à trois grandes questions
au cours de cette émission un noeud sur
jouez vous pas l'opposition à emmanuel
macron qui multiplie les chantiers que
ne peut pas renier la droite c'est ce
que vous demandera jean-francis pécresse
de votre évoqués pour la présidence de
votre parti et l'air pour une droite
vraiment de droite comme dit le favori
c'est nadège peljak qui viendra vous
poser cette question enfin 3 le sénat
renouvelait vous avez d'ailleurs
renforcer votre position doit-il être
constructif ou destructeur thèmes
qu'abordera à la fin de cette émission
mickaël szames s mais d'avoir une toute
première question d'actualité
[Musique]
c'est jour de fête nationale en espagne
madrid a adressé hier un ultimatum
barcelone pour que la catalogne renonce
à ses intentions sécessionnistes dans ce
bras de fer qui à vos faveurs l'espagne
je crois en un état unitaire et au
moment où on tente de faire avancer la
construction européenne
il ya un énorme paradoxe à subir cette
fragmentation identitaire mais au delà
je pense que la catalogne doit nous
inspirer plusieurs leçons la première
c'est que nous sommes en france un état
national unitaire et nous ne sommes pas
traverser
c'était peut-être le cas par le passé ma
part des tensions sécessionniste mais
surtout la catalogne
pour moi c'est une grande leçon vous
voyez pour que une région riche
acceptent de payer pour des régions
pauvres il faut en réalité un cadre dans
le cadre d'une communauté nationale et
je pense qu'au moment où on s'interroge
aussi sur la forme que demain doit
prendre l'europe
je pense qu'il faut que l'europe se
construisent avec les peuples avec les
nations parce que si demain on voulait
faire à marche forcée un état central
supranationale il y aurait ce genre de
risque de dislocation voilà c'est
important c'est une leçon solidarité que
le cadre national et une leçon
démocratie pour qu'une minorité accepte
la loi majorité une déclaration
d'indépendance de la catalogne pour vous
ce serait commettre l'irréparable
l'irréparable j'espère que non parce que
ce serait contre le droit d'ailleurs
constitutionnel espagnol avec les
risques que l'on parle même de risque de
guerre civile
alors j'espère que l'on sera pas projeté
60 en dix ans en arrière et violent
puisque cette histoire sans racines
aussi dans un moment historique beaucoup
beaucoup plus long mais je pense que
l'europe a mieux réagi je trouve qu'elle
n'avait réagi avec le break si je me
souviens où l'europe avait reçu deux ou
trois jours après leur excite la
première ministre écossaise encourageant
par là une forme de sécession alors que
là tout de suite l'europe le président a
grossi avec les différents pays ont dit
stop
nous ne reconnaîtrons pas une nuit
catalogne qui se diraient indépendant
fait vous craignez que la catalogne
aspire néanmoins d'autres régions en
espagne entier mais également dans
d'autres pays
européen est ce que pour vous c'est un
danger plus grand ou est-ce que c'est
plus grave aujourd'hui que le break site
ce qui se passe en espagne où on voit
l'état qui va si je pense que c'est
grave et c'est pour ça que je pense que
le cadre national on a dit que les états
nations étaient des figures de dépasser
je pense que non parce que on voit qu'en
france on a cet état unitaire on y tient
mais regardez la belgique a des soucis
le royaume uni je viens d'en parler
quelque part l'italie entre l'italie du
nord et l'italie du sud est puis
l'espagne donc je pense que il faut tout
faire quand on a un cadre national pour
pouvoir le préserver ce n'est pas une
figure qui appartient au passé
mais on voit bien que c'est d'abord une
solidarité c'est le lieu la source de
l'énergie démocratique en même temps et
l'europe demain ne peut se construire
que justement en composant avec les
peuples d'accord vous avez cédé beaucoup
sur cette solidarité en fait vous
reprochez koala aux indépendantistes
catalans d'être égoïste puisqu'ils
effective bien sûr oui égoïste bien sûr
c'est de l'égoïsme
mais c'est rompre je me souviens d'une
très belle phrase qu'il a prononcée
un peu avant sa mort de vaclav havel et
il disait attention la mondialisation
est porteur d'un dilemne mortifère d'un
côté une forme d'univers de faim plutôt
d'uniformisation ont tous pareils dans
le même moule et de l'autre côté une
fragmenté une fragmentation identitaire
la mondialisation peut susciter ce genre
de réaction et là on est sur le versant
justement de cette fragmentation de ce
repli qui à mon avis est malsain on le
voit bien qu est ce que le monde
aujourd'hui le monde sait des continents
qui s'organisent les empires qui
ressurgissent la chine la perse avec
l'iran la russie les états unis et nous
on va découper en confettis l'europe et
les nations européennes où va-t-on ce
sera un grave danger donc que c'est
votre leçon ce soir sur l'espagne bruno
retailleau la suite de l'épreuve de
vérité avec jean francis pécresse qui
nous rejoint le directeur des rédactions
radio classique
[Musique]
bonsoir jean françois richet le bon soir
bruno retailleau venge voir georges tu
as tu vu qu'on ne vouliez pas voté le
budget 2010 8 est ce que vous ne surjoue
est pas un peu votre opposition à
emmanuel macron non nous ne voterons pas
en état mais on peut la demander
voilà parce que comme parlementaire on
peut quand même heureusement encore
amendé les projets de loi de finances
non moi je pense c'est un constat c'est
que la france va pas bien même s'il ya
une embellie économique avec un peu plus
de croissance est quelque chose de
positif mais c'est justement ce moment
qu'il faut saisir pour faire de vraies
réformes
alors je pense que ce budget ne répond
pas aux deux problèmes endémiques de la
france le premier problème c'est la
dépense publique
le déficit de l'état va augmenter de 6,4
millions milliards d'euros donc plus de
dépenses publiques qu'on aura on ne
supprime que 1600 postes de dépenses
budgétaires
mais la défense budget public aux
sources ont cela de dépenses de l'état
que je vous ai dit allez aux dépenses de
rita baisse un peu et la france a un
problème c'est d'abord à 80% la dette et
crée d'ailleurs par l'état donc ne
répond pas ce budget à à la nécessaire
contraction de la dépense publique et de
l'état et surtout aux preuve de la
compétitivité de mois en mois qu'est ce
qu'on constate par rapport à l'allemagne
par exemple un déficit abyssal de
compétitivité avec la balance des
paiements et qu'est ce qu'on va nous
proposer
c'est de taper un peu plus sur les
entreprises qui vont supporter 3,3
milliards de prélèvements
supplémentaires
ça n'est pas recréer les conditions de
la croissance et en plus je pense qu'il
est injuste il est injuste vis-à-vis des
retraités allant on en parlera dans le
cadre du plfss avec la csg il est
injuste vis-à-vis des familles on en
parlera aussi vis-à-vis de la politique
familiale et vis-à-vis des propriétaires
il ya eu une forme et je pense que c'est
le maquereau nismo cia il crée des
antagonismes je trouve il ya un certain
nombre de gestes forts quand même comme
la suppression de l'sf vous auriez bien
aimé faire ça vous vous souteniez
françois françois fillon qui était pour
la suppression de l'isf alors
précisément et ça c'est toute la
politique finalement d'emmanuel ma
crainte c'est finalement du mi temps
c'est finalement de la demi mesure en
même temps on lui dira exactement on
supprime en partie l'usf et en même
temps on fait les filles c'est à dire
que on réinvente l'impôt sur les petites
fortunes parce que vous savez très
grandes fortunes
vous savez que pour les patrimoines de
plus de dix millions dix millions
d'euros l'essentiel 90% est constitué de
portefeuilles d'actions bien donc ça
signifie que le nouvel impôt sur ces
petites fortunes qu'on appelle ici va
reposer sur l'immobilier exclusivement
et donc sur les petit alors vous vous
nous dites c'est le président des très
riches alors est ce que vous dites je
dis que c'est en tout cas un argument
qui apporte de l'eau au moulin de ceux
qui veulent bien le dire je pense moi je
ne raconte rien vous le dit pas non
parce que moi j'aurais préféré que on
supprime l'isf parce que nulle part ou
presque
en europe il n'existe et parce
qu'aujourd'hui en france le problème
numéro un c'est notre compétitivité
c'est de créer de l'emploi et pour créer
de l'emploi il faut favoriser
l'investissement et la modernisation
d'investissement de l'appareil productif
français
alors elle macron poursuit néanmoins le
rythme de ses réformes il a reçu
aujourd'hui les syndicats et le patronat
pour lampard et de la formation de
l'apprentissage et de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage
tout ça ça va quand même à un rythme
tambour battant c'est trop rapide vous
avez l'impression que non là n'est pas
le rythme et ont quand même qui fait un
certain nombre de choses que vous auriez
pu faire vous nommez que la droite et
échoue on est d'accord on a on a perdu
en deux vous auriez les faire on a en
had pendant plusieurs décennies on n'a
pas fait le travail
donc pour moi c'est pas la toise qui me
permet de juger d'une politique si elle
est bonne ou l est pas bonne une
politique est bonne si elle répond aux
défis que doit relever la france
et j'observe j'observe que sur les
ordonnances on a dit beaucoup de bien ça
changera assez peu de choses finalement
sur le chômage
en réalité on va créer un droit à
l'indemnisation des démissions sur fonds
publics
on va étatisé et des travailleurs
indépendants peut être aussi et il est
travailleur indépendant mais c'est une
mauvaise idée de faire ça je ne vois pas
les réformes structurelles mais c'est
une mauvaise idée de faire ça parce que
ça peut favoriser la panse de l'est
baptisation de de ce qu'ils ont non mais
là c'est une craie le nouveau droit le
nouveau garde sur le museau ou mauvaise
idée ça créera un effet d'aubaine une
grande discussion
on sait que c'est plusieurs milliards
certains disent la première année 14
entre deux vies parce que c'est l'été 14
lots bien mais c'est des milliards et
des milliards
donc vouloir réformer l'assurance
chômage
en proposant de nouveaux déficits peu
ouverte on est par ailleurs étatisée
l'assurance chômage c'est à mon avis la
plus mauvaise chose parce que les
partenaires sociaux sont pas enclins à
faire des réformes
supprimer la garantie de l'état pour
l'avenir oui ce serait une bonne réforme
la garantie de l'état sur quoi sur le
label da l'unedic 1 c'est sur le deux
pas sur le passé mais sur la grange
images chaleur parce que ça mettrait les
partenaires sociaux fassent alors devant
leurs responsabilités et c'est ça la
bonne réforme est en partie parce que je
pense que il faut aussi créer un appétit
pour que syrte en de personnes puissent
travailler il ya des chômeurs qui sont
au chômage parce qu'il ne trouve
vraiment pas ils font des efforts et et
d'autre je pense qu'ils sont maintenus
dans cet état parce que ya pas
suffisamment d'incitation alors vous
vous parlez d'étatisation de l'assurance
chômage le patron des patrons père
gattaz air critique lui réservé sur une
direction tripartite en tous les cas
c'est le mot qui l'emploie mais
néanmoins on écoute là tout à l'heure à
sa sortie de l'elysée
il se félicite de la méthode macron
cette méthode permet de sortir de cet
enfer et de faire des réformes qui
convienne à tout le monde aux salariés
aux chômeurs aux entreprises et qu'on
arrive à faire ce modèle que je
préconise d'une économie d'excellence
profondément humaine profondément
respectueuse environnement cette
triptyque cette trilogie
eh bien ça marchera donc cette
concertation me paraît intéressante de
cette méthode
continuons regardons c'est un moyen pour
discuter mettre les choses sur la table
alors est-ce que vous n'êtes pas un peu
plus royaliste que le roi
non pas du tout j'essaie de seix
j'essaie de faire les choses et de voir
les choses de façon rationnelle de façon
assez froide et et au sénat vous savez
j'ai voté les premiers textes d'ailleurs
j'ai voté les ordonnances je considérais
que malgré tout même si c'est pas
suffisant
ça va dans le bon sens pour reprendre
les ordonnances mais il y avait une
proclamation départ on devait inverser
la hiérarchie des normes la loi la
branche et l'entreprise
au bout du bout qu'est ce qu'on a c'est
encore plus de pouvoirs aux accords de
branche plutôt qu aux accords
d'entreprises donc il faut il faut
modérer les choses et il faut assurer
votre association mais c'est mon
appréciation je pense que il aurait
fallu faire sauter les seuls à ce que
tout le monde du vin on a on a en france
des seuils
on a quand même en france pour peu que
vous embauchez une ou deux personnes
c'est à 49 ans boucher une ou deux
personnes de plus il vous tombe sur le
dos 34 ou 35 contraintes administratives
qui vont vous créez un surcoût de 3 ou 4
point de masse salariale supplémentaire
est pour ça qu en france on a trois fois
plus d'entreprises de moins de 50
salariés que de plus de 50 salariés et
c'est celui-là on les a renforcés donc
il ya des bonnes choses et il y en a de
moins bonnes on n'est pas forcé parce
que je sais que depuis des mois on
voudrait nous culpabiliser d'être dans
une opposition y compris lorsqu elle est
intelligente
je pense qu'une démocratie c'est aussi
une opposition et une majorité on va
quand même pas on l'a bien vu avec la
sphère du drapeau européen
on va quand même pas laisser le monopole
de l'opposition soit à madame le pen est
dans un triste état mais quand même
qu'ils sont partis ou soit monsieur
mélenchon cas une forme de romantisme
révolutionnaire mais qui mènerait la
france dans le mur
donc en fait macron injuste insuffisant
je peux juste jeux wii injuste oui parce
que il a cette propension à antagonisent
et les gens il ya les montricher
l'émouvant ceux qui possèdent des
actions que caetera et puis il ya les
pauvres propriétaires ya les retraités
qu'il faut massacrer puis il ya les
actifs n'est pas vraiment bien les
permis d'engager la guerre les individus
de mettre l'argent de l'orienter ou où
l'épargné
je suis en tout cas vers l'économie qui
créent de l'emploi vers l'économie
active mais mal ses idées que
l'immobilier l'argent qu'on va
immobiliser dans de la pierre par
définition c'est pas un argent qui crée
beaucoup de richesses que vous voulez
rire
je suis il ya encore quelques semaines
j'étais président de région je veux dire
que l'immobilier le secteur du logement
le bâtiment a connu une crise énorme
il a beaucoup souffert des milliers
d'emplois de supprimer et c'est un
secteur qui crée de l'emploi est
aujourd'hui avec les filles on va taper
le logement donc on va taper ces
entreprises là et en plus avec la
politique justement de réforme du
logement
il peut y avoir aussi
entre le logement public et le logement
privé un effet de tenaille qui casse la
dynamique était en train de reprendre
sur un secteur qui est un secteur
stratégique
pourquoi est ce que les start up serait
plus noble parce que c'est dans le
numérique que le fait de poser des
parpaings que de faire des maisons que
de faire des infrastructures en france
on a besoin des deux je veux dire
pourquoi punir les uns plus tôt que les
autres
pourquoi punir les retraités plutôt que
les lézards les actifs les retraités it
c'est vrai ils ont pendant toute leur
vie ils ont travaillé souvent bien dur
pour accumuler un petit capital
c'est pas pour autant que ce capital là
il est juste de refaire payer un prix
vis-à-vis d'autres générations il faut
un équilibre il se trouve cette équipée
pour vous c'est quoi c'est une forme
c'est une idéologie contre une contre
une certaine france une france
provinciale ou alors il est clair normal
je le mets pas ce nom je pense que le
maquereau nisme est quelque chose de
compliqué il a énormément d'intelligence
et c'est un peu un prodige de la
politique de ce point de vue là il a
compris d'ailleurs la communication ce
qui fait que il est capable
d'interpréter un certain nombre de rôles
successivement en revanche je pense
qu'il est très manichéen dans sa façon
de voir les choses
il dit la ville de l'est au rivage run
justement ils dynamitent le clivage
droite gauche mais en même temps il
réinstalle un autre clivage entre lui et
les autres lui et les extrêmes
c'est pas un hyper centrisme c'est
plutôt un un auto un égocentrisme si
j'ose dire et c'est ça qui est gênante
il ya des familles de pensée qui sont
des grandes polarités depuis des années
des années et il peut pas lui seul les
récapituler il aimerait justement faire
en sorte qu' il ya le camp du bien quand
du progrès et le camp du mal et ça c'est
quelque chose qui me gêne dans ce qui
vous différencie encore aujourd'hui il y
a entre autres la question de la
suppression de postes de fonctionnaires
dans le budget 2010 8 ya 1600 postes en
moins dans le sol et de l'état peut-être
légers indiqué ils en foutent rien
combien
en tout cas beaucoup plus lui même
admettons que je prenne sa propre toile
lui s'est engagé à faire peu moins de
130 me 125000 et là on en fait 1600 dont
le même en reprenant sur le quinquennat
même en reprenant ses éléments de
langage et ses objectifs on voit qu'ils
sont très en dessous et encore une fois
pourquoi est ce que le fait mais vous
parce que ya une embellie économique et
que certaines rivier vous en voudriez
combien parce que vous vous dites depuis
le début de cette émission qui va pas
plusieurs plus à verser loin bien sûr
mais quel est votre proposition il en
faut encore est ce que vous voulez faire
des économies dans la dépense publique
ça c'est un vieux débat il ya plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'emplois qu'il
faut réussir à contracter par plusieurs
effets moi je constate aussi par exemple
pour les aides aux entreprises
les régions s'occupent des entreprises
pourquoi est ce que dans
l'administration régionale de l'état il
y a des dizaines de fonctionnaires qui
s'occupe des entreprises qu'on laisse
les régions frère arrêtons les doublons
en matière agricole en matière de
politiques notamment économiques et je
pense qu'il faudra déverrouiller aussi
un moment ou un autre le temps de
travail c'est comme ça qu'on pourra
gagner en compétitivité
et puis en nombre de postes pourquoi
parce qu'on voit bien que la fonction
publique
la fonction publique est en train de
s'appauvrir les fonctionnaires les
agents publics étaient dans la rue parce
qu'ils sont en train de s'appauvrir il
ya le gel des pointes à 10 mais demain
si on veut justement que cette fonction
publique puisse être revalorisées on ne
peut pas être le pays d'europe qui a la
fonction publique la plus pléthorique
alors françois fillon avait proposé à
l'époque 500000 d'autres avoir proposé
un peu moins mais en tout cas 1600 sur
un budget c'est rien du tout je pense
que ça sans doute été un marchandage
pour les ordonnances je pense que
peut-être que vis-à-vis d'un surnombre
de syndicats monsieur macron a à dire
bah on va coûter je supprimerai très
post
et puis bah vous descendez pas trop dans
la rue à un mot sur un ministre papa sow
de bercy qui viennent de l air vos amis
je pense à nicolas hulot vous amis aussi
le ministre de la transition écologique
qui a des états d'âme il a dîné en
tête-à-tête avec emmanuel macron hier
soir c'est ce que nous apprend le monde
ce soir pour un nécessaire moment
d'ajustement c'est l'expression donné
la ville où qu'ils se trouvent qu'ils se
retrouvent finalement très heureux est
ce que vous vous pensez que ça va durer
vous êtes très heureux qu'il soit encore
là on va coûter je suis un comptable de
ses états d'âme
oui je veux dire que je le respecte pour
l'instant il faut qu'il fasse ses
preuves
moi je le trouvais très bon à la
télévision maintenant communiste c'est
autre chose et pour un dossier que je
connais bien notre dame des landes
il a plutôt tout faux il a nommé un
certain de ses amis cas la médiation ses
amis d'ailleurs ont demandé à une
société dont les deux propriétaires sont
très proches de monsieur hulot de faire
un bilan de carbone je trouve ça tout je
trouve que l'on mélange un peu les
choses quand même voilà merci jean franc
suisse ce la suite de l'épreuve de
vérité tout de suite avec nadège peljak
de la fp l'épreuve de vérité avec life
fait
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur retailleau
bonsoir n'a déchu jack alors l'élection
du président des républicains c'est en
décembre
bon ben alors vous allez nous dire pour
qui vous a évoqué les gars vont siéger
les biens non non je prononcerai pas le
nom fatidique je veux sans doute non je
dis pas que je veux trépout je veux très
content simplement ce que je dis c'est
que je suis président d'un groupe
parlementaire au sénat qui est le
premier groupe notamment du sénat et ça
m'impose un certain nombre comment 10h
de contrainte est aussi une règle de
conduite
mon rôle c'est de rassembler voilà donc
d'être invité je vais voir en tout cas
j'attends puisque maintenant on connaît
les quatre candidats il va y avoir les
projets je vais regarder les projets je
me prononcerai je verrai si je prends
position ou si je ne prends pas position
mais la lune déjà président du groupe et
leur quand vous souteniez non dans dans
le pour la présidence du parti à
l'époque je n'avais pas pris position il
y avait bruno le maire et puis il y
avait nicolas sarkozy et quand j'avais
été élu président de groupe gt on savait
déjà mon accointances et pour une
élection présidentielle
évidemment quand on est pris donc gros
bras en tous les cas vous devez prendre
position mais en tout cas ce que je veux
dire c'est que je vais cette question 1
quand j'aurais lu regardé les projets
des uns des autres et 2 je vérifierai
bien avec l'état du groupe et notamment
s'il ya menace ou pas sur l'unité du
groupe
d'accord mais enfin on va pas se
raconter d'histoires c'est vrai que
monsieur wauquiez est quand même archi
favori oui est-ce que vous pensez que ça
uns des autres où une ou une des autres
candidats peut il pourrait le mettre en
danger
bakou tenons mais déjà c'est bien il ya
4 il ya quelques jours nous disait là il
va être tout seul pour déjà il ya quatre
candidats c'est important voire à mesure
oui bah oui parce que faire une élection
avec un seul candidat
vous imaginez un christ hyper il
l'écrira exactement que vous aurez loupé
de nous adresser dos comme moins jeunes
en cours pas ce soir ces critiques mais
voilà il ya quatre candidats laurent
wauquiez est sans doute favori il ya
d'autres
entrant d'art sans doute vous exagérez
non mais c'est qu'une élection c'est
toujours un combat et donc il faut que
le meilleur gagne pas avoir une grosse
surprise on l'a on a déjà connu ça à un
an des élections
oui mais quand même beaucoup de voix qui
s'élèvent contre un candidat je parle de
monsieur wauquiez qui est jugé trop à
droite
flirtant même avec le fn je crois que
c'est valérie pécresse qui parle de
porosité et christian estrosi sur cette
antenne à utiliser un mot assez dur les
coutures christian estrosi
il est une réalité c'est que ce qui a
représentent encore la droite ou en tout
cas qui prétend de la représenter me
paraissent de plus en plus radicalisés
radicaliser non ça c'est une arête fait
peur mais on a compris que c'était une
pierre dans le jardin de monsieur
wauquiez
ça c'est une rhétorique qui vient de la
gauche que longtemps la gauche a utilisé
ses rosiers de gauche contre la droite
contre la droite et comme soeur de gaz
incapacitant pour intimider la droite je
pense qu'on ne devrait pas surtout des
des membres de notre famille politique
je ne sais pas encore s'ils se
reconnaissent commandes s'établit
politique mais on ne devrait pas
utiliser ces procédés d'intimidation qui
viennent de la gauche de la vieille
gauche d'ailleurs donc laurent wauquiez
à aucun moment à aucun moment n'a parlé
d'un accord avec le front national il
vient de rappeler il ya quelques jours
que c'était pour lui une histoire il a
beau dire je ne ferai jamais d'accord
avec le front national en impression
vous savez que c'est le sparadrap qui
est du capitaine haddock là celui qui
lui colle à la peau à chaque ont leur
sort vous pour lui pour vous c'est
d'ailleurs pourquoi parce que je pense
que en france on n'a jamais supporté une
droite autrement que finalement soumise
à l'hégémonie culturelle et idéologique
de la gauche andré siegfried ya bien
longtemps disait ça il disait une droite
moderne c'est souvent une gauche ancien
voilà donc effectivement laurent
wauquiez a une ligne qui assume
clairement un positionnement idéologique
et je pense que c'est plutôt pouzy ni
droite vraiment degré et j'observe que
et j'observe que avec emmanuel macron on
parlait tout à l'heure d'économie on
voit bien que il essaie de marcher sur
les plates-bandes économique de la
droite si la droite n'était que la
réponse
à des problèmes économiques il y aurait
plus d espace pour elle je pense que il
faut que la droite puisse répondre à la
double angoisse française le
déclassement économique à travers le
chômage de masse l'ascenseur social qui
est bloqué mais en même temps la
dépossession culturel avec des notions
aussi bien qui touche à la civilisation
au cadre national et il veut y répondre
et c'est pour ça que on dit mais il est
trop à droite
en réalité il a une ligne qui est salie
et on verra bien puisqu'il ya une
élection
kelly va l'emporter alors rendez il est
trop à droite
dans les rangs et leur en parle de
cristaux de monsieur estrosi
mais également il ya gérald darmanin
pour qui le péché ça a été de ne pas
savoir choisir entre marine le pen et
emmanuel macron au second tour de la
présidentielle vous même par exemple
est-ce que vous vous sentez visé quel
était votre choix en anjou on apprenait
on était mais on est toujours été clair
y compris l'ayant laurent wauquiez en
dix ans pas une seule voie pour madame
le pen donc les choses étaient claires
simplement non mais moi j'ai choisi
monsieur d'armagh mardi c'était là mais
parce que mais parce que dans un certain
nombre pour un certain nombre de nos
électeurs prononcer ce mot c'était
contribué justement à l'est indiquent
alizés parce que pendant des mois il
avait fait campagne contre eux il
fallait d'abord dire ma rage contre le
front national
et on a tous été très très clair
maintenant ce que je veux dire pour
monsieur d'hermann à quelques autres ils
sont les instruments dans les mains de
monsieur macron pour déstabiliser la
droite
je suis mac on l'a reconnu plusieurs
mois sur les antennes d'une émission
d'ailleurs deux chaînes publiques pour
dire maintenant l'objectif c'est de
déstabiliser la droite il a déstabilisé
la gauche pendant l'élection
présidentielle
il a nommé un premier ministre de droite
pour déstabiliser la droite pour les
élections législatives c'est
parfaitement normal que ces ministres
qui sont issus de notre famille
politique joue le rôle pour lesquels
pour lequel ils ont été désignés c'est à
dire continuer à affaiblir la droite
évidemment oui alors mais entre monsieur
estrosi par exemple et tous les autres
qui sont macro compatibles et puis
wauquiez qui veut lui il ne droite de
droite
je crois que vous ne contredirai pas sur
ce plan là on a quand même l'impression
que
vous avez du plomb dans l'oeil vous le
parti des républicains ça peut tenir
combien de temps comme ça on
on a sans doute du plomb dans l aile
comme vous dites puisque on a dû assumer
deux défaites
j'observe simplement quand même que les
sénatoriales qui ont été une victoire
qui ont été d'ailleurs une défaite pour
un marge puisque le groupe en marche
avait 29 sénateurs
il en a plus maintenant que 21 donc
voyez même si l'année a été difficile on
redresse un petit peu la tête mais il ya
encore beaucoup de chemin à faire mais
vous risquez vous fracturé une peu avoir
toujours ce risque parce que après des
défaites le risque là encore de la
fracture le risque là des visions et on
voit bien qu'il ya des gens qui souffle
sur la division j'entends ce les belles
voix justement qui proclame qui font
profession de foi de tolérance etc et
qui joue de l'excommunication
c'est à dire que monsieur wauquiez ou
tel ou tel ne convient pas et c'est vrai
tu allusion à monsieur estrosi qui a
demandé tout simplement son exclusion du
parti c'est ça c'est pas raisonnable
franchement ça n'est pas raisonnable
voilà quand je suis allé moi dans le
nord pour soutenir la liste qui était
mené par part du candidat ait l'air sur
l'autre liste opposée à la liste nerfs
il y avait monsieur darmanin il y avait
monsieur darmanin moi j'aurais aimé que
tous ces ministres qui viennent de chez
nous et la même élégance la même
cohérence que bruno le maire bruno le
maire il est rentré à en marche
point final la politique c'est la clarté
la clarté des choix
moi je critiquerai personne s'il pense
que emmanuel macron c'est la panacée qui
retrouvant nez mail macro une sorte de
messie dans lequel ils ont toujours rêvé
pas qu'ils aillent ils le soutiennent et
il ya une logique et moi je veux dire
c'est un choix qu'il faut respecter si
tout de suite si ça correspond à leurs
convictions et pas seulement un calcul
de carrière encore une fois bruno le
maire lui il a fait ce choix vous
trouvez que darmanin à un plan de
carrière dans la tête en faisant ce
qu'il fait non un coup chez vous je
m'accroche je pense que vraiment de dire
ça serait inconvenant de ma part
évidemment mais il dit lui même qu'il
n'est pas opportuniste un kit eric assez
de mal saisi les opportunités c'est ce
qu'il disait lui-même dans un portrait
de lui
publié par les échos week-end encore lui
récemment dans
dans le figaro gérald darmanin il
demandait à ceux qui ont accompagné le
trocadéro c'était vous au premier au
premier plan aux premières loges de
s'excuser car c'est vous qui avait
entraîné là une forme de radicalité en
phase avec une toute petite fraction de
l'électorat vous excuser alors que non
que non que non que non mais vous voyez
tout tout tout ces gens là qui essaie de
porter des anathèmes sur les uns des
autres
voilà qui s'en prennent aux uns et aux
autres qui utilise les procédés de la
gauche pour encore une fois prononcé des
mots qui sont très très dur des
excommunications
moi j'ai connu monsieur darmana et on
n'a pas changé de programme qui était
très allants dans la campagne de
françois fillon jusqu'à un moment donné
ou peut-être que soit échaudés par un
certain nombre de dossiers soit parce
qu'ils considéraient qu'il ne pouvait
plus gagner il a quitté le navire
je n'ai jamais critiqué simplement mais
de là à ce qu'ils reprennent ces
thèmes-là de la radicalisation en
réalité du trocadéro alors que cette
foule 3 cadero croyez-moi je l' ai vu il
n'y était pas est ce que par exemple
françois baroin est un dangereux
radicaliser que monsieur chatel qui
était aussi au trocadéro ou que mon
collègue président du groupe à
l'assemblée
monsieur jacob est en même temps à
radicaliser cette fois je les ai vus et
venait de la france entière et venait
pas vous savez alors que des mots
arrondissement europe de paris justement
pour parler du trocadéro on dit que
c'est sens commun qu'il l'a organisé
avec monsieur fillon pour rappeler
peut-être aux gens qui nous regardent
qui se souviennent plus très bien ce que
c'est que le trocadéro donc on organise
un grand rassemblement au trocadéro pour
essayer de remonter la pente
bon sens commun qui est l'émanation
politique de la manif pour tous je suis
très pédagogue ce soit royal a décidé
dimanche d'organiser une manifestation
en fait trois grandes tables rondes avec
des intellectuels et
et des politiques dont vous serez
peut-être mais on ne vous entend
alors ils annulent ou pas parce qu'on
n'a pas très bien compris aujourd'hui on
nous dit qu'ils annulent leurs
manifestations
ensuite on lui dit que nous alors
peut-être que vous sauriez vous la
formation que j'avais moi et que j'ai lu
dans la journée c'est que ils
maintiennent à huis clos je crois pour
leur propre mouvement le samedi mais que
ce qui était prévu le dimanche avait été
à table ronde à laquelle auquel vous
deviez assistait d'ailleurs le dimanche
avec d'autres bien sûr et les propos de
leur président sur marion maréchal-le
pen en cristaux moi j'avais indiqué que
dans ces conditions je ne pouvais pas y
aller mais hors de question pour moi
durant il a franchi la ligne rouge mais
c'est bien le porter
simplement résident donc de sens commun
qui a dit qu'il était prêt à faire
alliance à certaines conditions ces
mêmes
bien sûr ces propos si j'ose dire
franchement ils ont jeté un trouble et
c'est des propos en tout cas si on
prétend être à l air on ne peut pas
faire d' accord de prêt ou de loin avec
le front national ou avec une le pen
qu'elle soit marion qu'elle soit marine
pensent comme moi un boulet pour celles
d'un homme et non pas qu ils ont ils
manqué quand même non non ils ont été
visés non ils ont et non jeunes
hurlaient compris ils ont été victime
d'une diabolisation
voilà donc personne les a obligés à dire
alors ça m'a obligé à dire à monsieur b
adresse que je suis bien je suis prêt à
faire et d'ailleurs c'est avec marion
maréchal-le pen a ils ont été victimes
avant cela notamment on parlait le
trocadéro c'est pas eux qui ont organisé
le trocadéro c'est monsieur stefanini
d'ailleurs bon qui était le directeur de
campagne bien et aujourd'hui justement
les propos du président sont d'autant
plus comment dirais-je inconcevable que
il ne faut pas donner d'arguments et cet
argument d'une possible alliance est un
argument qu'on doit absolument réfuté
voilà parce que le front national trompe
le peuple ne défend pas le peuple et je
pense qu'il ne saurait y avoir
d'alliance pas et l'air ou avec les
mouvements associés avec une forme ou
une autre du front national
les choses sont très très clairs chacun
l'a rappelé d'ailleurs ce mouvement a
fait
suit un rectificatif collectif pour dire
qu' ils entendent bien rester dans cette
ligne là et ne pas céder justement à ce
type d'alliance et pour moi c'est être
un point qui était très important
merci nadège un mot sur françois fillon
puisqu'on a appris tout à l'heure qu'il
avait été placé sous statut de témoin
assisté un pour escroqueries aggravées
toujours la sphère de de l'emploi
présumé fictif de son épouse et de ses
enfants il a déjà été mis en examen dans
cette affaire là on voit l'étau
judiciaire se resserre
non non j'ai observe que de les deux
enfants qui avaient été engagés dans la
procédure sont ressortis comme témoin
assisté et non pas comme mise en examen
et le statut de témoin assisté
c'est ce qui permet de ne pas ressortir
comme étant mise en examen mais vous me
l'a perdu je n'ai pas je n'ai pas cette
information mais si c'est le statut de
témoin assisté j'observe que ça n'est
pas le fait d'être mise en examen mais
je ne veux pas réagir plus parce que
cette information vous me la donnez je
l'apprends de votre bouche
allez la suite de l'épreuve de vérité
tout de suite avec michaël szames s de
public sénat
[Musique]
en sports michael 11 ans michel
monsarrat retailleau bonsoir mikel san
ace alors si on comprend bien la
position de gérard larcher il va senna
plus constructif que destructif est ce
que cette position est satisfait c'est
le sénat n'est pas l'assemblée nationale
on n'est pas une assemblée parlementaire
qui réagit à l'émotion médiatique à
celle de la rue etc
il ya toujours une distance et ce que
nous avons pratiqué y compris avec le
quinquennat françois hollande où nous
avons voté des lois je tiens à le
rappeler de nombreuses lois que j'ai
aussi voter ça toujours été une
opposition intelligente donc oui nous
sommes l'opposition qui sauvent rire
nous pratiquons une opposition si une
opposition intelligente et quand
viendront des textes où nous aurons
l'occasion d'où notamment nous opposer
on va parler peut-être dû on en a parlé
déjà du budget la part lui le fait
simplement on est ni dans l'obstruction
ni dans la complaisance ni à la
connivence et tout peut-être juste eu un
mot sur le budget que vous avez pas dit
dieu tout à l'heure où vous irez jusqu'à
la deuxième lecture savait que l'année
dernière vous avez fait une motion
préalable moi je lui dois m avait rejeté
vous savez que l'équivalent restait
cette année justement l'an dernier on
sait maintenant que le budget de qui
avait été concocté
l'an dernier par monsieur hollande et
son gouvernement a été sans doute un des
budgets les plus truc est insincère dico
des cons et bah oui parce que la cour
des comptes elle a un langage châtié
comme et les françaises de jeunes
verront leur parlera dacquois là et
c'est le sénat voyez c'est le sénat qui
n'avait pas voulu aller alors on avait
été critiqué à l'époque en dira le sénat
ne vote pas ne va pas jusqu'à la
deuxième partie du budget qu'est-ce que
vous aujourd'hui c'est nous qui avons
raison
qu'est ce qu'on essaie de justifier
d'ailleurs par la position d'accorder
contre le budget tel que l'or le le
budget les critiques on peut formuler ce
sont pas des critiques sur ma sincérité
je pense que quand il est il est plus de
ce point de vue la plus juste avant sur
une nature si vous aurez du coût et du
coup rien ne s'oppose la crasse qu on
aille jusqu à la deuxième partie la
forme d'opposition que
vous allez prendre recevoir de l'aide
pour les téléspectateurs dépenses et
recettes
il ya deux parties dans le budget on
examine première puis ensuite je libère
on va prendre peut-être un exemple un
peu frappant de l'opposition vous voulez
mener notamment sur le texte sur la loi
contre le terrorisme
il ya eu ce qu'on appelle une commission
mixte paritaire qui finalement résume un
petit peu l'arrangement qu'on peut
trouver entre l'assemblée et le sénat
clic parce que vous avez mis à un
mouchoir sur vos valeurs alors que
pourquoi pourquoi on a fait un beau
choix surtout valeur non pas du tout
nous est ce que vous avez formulé des
propositions qui avaient été totalement
rejetée par le ministre de l'intérieur
le sénat pas du tout au contraire
non vous êtes ce que je veux dire dans
la mesure où en france un visage c'est
que nous avons voté tous les textes qui
était proposée à l'époque par monsieur
hollande sur l'état d'urgence et c'est
au sénat que nous avons forgé les outils
de sécurité l'assemblée et etienne
étaient molles et c'est le sénat qui a
forgé les meilleurs outils de sécurité
je peux pas les énumérer mais une demi
douzaine ensuite pour ce qui nous
concerne
non on est conforme c'est à dire que on
a dit au gouvernement vous prenez vos
responsabilités
nous il nous semble que la menace est
élevée vous devriez rester dans l'état
d'urgence mais si vous voulez en sortir
alors attention attention il ya les
libertés publiques il faut trouver le la
bonne mesure il faut savoir placer le
curseur entre la sécurité et la liberté
parce que si l'état d'urgence c'est une
loi qui est qui n'est pas permanent qui
est temporaire et donc on peut réhausser
le degré de sécurité
par contre sur une loi qui devient
permanente à ce moment là il ya aussi le
poids des libertés que c'est une loi qui
va renforcer notre sécurité se démente
vos camarades députés
je pense qu'après marchais je pense
qu'après marseille on voit bien que la
menace est toujours élevé donc la
question que je pose le gouvernement
soit le gouvernement pense que la menace
est toujours aussi élevées alors il
aurait dû garder et maintenir l'état
d'urgence soit ils pensent que la menace
est sans doute moins élevés et qu'on
peut en sortir il a beaucoup plus de
renseignements que moi et alors il faut
justement à voir ce bon milieu entre le
niveau de sécurité et le niveau des
libertés publiques en cas de
c'est aggraver vous prendrez en défaut
le gouvernement non il s'agit pas de
prendre en défaut je pense que ça va
tout à l'heure on objecter en parlaient
certains d'entre nous parle de
radicalisation radicalisation elle est
dans certains quartiers des
radicalisations c'est l'islamisme
radical
voilà et de ce point de vue là il faut
que le gouvernement prenne la pleine
mesure
j'ai observé que le ministre que l'on de
l'intérieur avait limogé un préfet un
préfet de région
c'était d'ailleurs un excellent vrai
fait franchement franchement là encore
préfet de région en piste mais c'est un
bouc émissaire
moi ce que j'attends du gouvernement ce
que j'attends de monsieur collomb c'est
de me dire comment est ce qu'il fait en
sorte que le droit d'asile ne devienne
pas une machine à fabriquer des
clandestins et qu'on puisse les
raccompagner il ya moins de 10 % c'est
pas moi qui le dit c'est la cour des
comptes il ya moins de 10% de ceux qui
sont entrés par effraction qui ont voulu
droit d'asile mais qui ne justifie pas
qu'ils sont reconduites à la frontière
donc c'est c'est ce que le président m'a
qu'on doit nous proposer avec son
gouvernement
comment fait-on justement pour régler
pour juguler une image une immigration
qui est une immigration de masse alors
le grand enjeu des dernières
sénatoriales pour le chef de l'état
c'était évidemment la perspective de
mener des réformes constitutionnelles
avec la majorité des trois cinquièmes
qu'il n'a pas finalement on va écouter
le président du sénat gérard larcher qui
dit ne pas vouloir jouer l'obstruction
d'une façon globale sur cette question
il ya des convergences il y à des
convergences mais on les côtes car il
fixe des lignes rouges
on verra si c'est les deux mais deux
lignes c'est quoi la tentation de
constitutionnaliser le mode électoral
je reviens en arrière et j'ai changé il
ya pas longtemps avec l'ancien président
du conseil constitutionnel jean louis
debré je ne devrais n'avait pas voulu
constitutionnaliser y compris le scrutin
majoritaire à deux tours pour l'élection
législative
parce qu'il nous faut des soupapes de
sécurité en cas de crise politique le
jour vous l'avez constitutionnaliser
vous avez perdu cette soupape politique
deuxième chose qui me semble contraire
la démocratie c'est le cumul non cumul
dans le temps
notamment pour les élus locaux est-ce
que vous avez les mêmes lignes rouges
que le président du sénat oui j'ai les
mêmes d'ailleurs on en a souvent parlé
il a raison il faut c'est aux électeurs
de dire si quelqu'un fait trop de mandat
ou pas voilà c'est tout et j'ajoute un
point c'est que nous ne sommes pas a
priori on a le plus beau style
absolument dans une révision
concessionnels et nous sommes pas a
priori hostile à la baisse du nombre de
députés et de sénateurs à une condition
c'est que les territoires qui sont
fragiles qui ont peu de démographie
continue être représentée puisque
aujourd'hui avec 348 sénateurs vous avez
moins de dix départements qui élisent un
sénateur seulement mais avec cette
réforme on passerait de sept
départements avec un seul sénateur a
sans doute plus de 55 et donc il ya un
problème et il faut justement que dans
cette révision constitutionnelle on dise
une bonne fois pour toutes que
l'assemblée représentent une population
donc une démographie mais que le sénat
représente les territoires c'est
d'ailleurs constitutionnel et il faut
que l'élection soit déconnectée de la
seule démographie et qu' il puisse y
avoir des territoires y compris pauvres
en habitant en démographie pour qu'ils
puissent être représentées sur la
réforme constitutionnelle vous soyez
d'accord donc si on comprend bien pour
le conseil supérieur de la magistrature
pour la cohérence de la république pour
que de supprimer les former ou supprimés
bref je pense qu'on peut d accord je
pense qu'on peut trouver des ressorts à
la condition par exemple que le csm ne
devienne pas un organe corporatiste pas
question que je n'ai pas fait sous
françois hollande où vous l'avez
proposés pourquoi maintenant non il va
ya vait pas vous avez très bien que ça
n'était pas uniquement un objet il y
avait un autre objet c'est cet objet lac
pour le canot oms est opposé le conseil
supérieur de magistrature dyer avait été
approuvée ce n'est pas là que il y avait
eu un un blocage c'était sur un autre
sujet donc pour résumer oui à une
éventuelle révision mais ça n'est pas un
chèque en blanc
les conditions sont très claires et si
on a le sentiment que cette révision
conçu une aile se fait sur le dos de la
france périphérique de ces territoires
notamment ruraux ou de villes moyennes
alors ce sera non sérieux donc et ce
sera donc clairement d'accord pas ce
cadeau en tout cas ce qu'on comprend
c'est pas de faire un cadeau c'est pas
monsieur c'est pas les beaux yeux de
monsieur
kron c'est l'intérêt de la france des
territoires de france je crois que
monsieur macron comprends pas cette
france territoriales voilà et parce
qu'il a on a bien vu ce que tout le
monde dit être peut-être sepa panne mais
en tout cas il a accumulé beaucoup de
maladresses et d'ailleurs qui ont fait
notre bonheur si j'eusse tir puisque ça
favorisait les élections sénatoriales et
et notre groupe et l'air au sénat mais
très franchement nous ne ferons pas une
révision constitutionnelle qui aurait
justement pour effet d'aggraver la
fracture territoriale français le reste
peu de temps mais quand même sur la cour
des comptes qui a dit finalement les
territoires se portait bien aujourd'hui
les collectivités en tout cas vous
n'êtes pas à l'aise donc vous pouvez
faire des efforts c'est ce qu'on entend
non en fait la cour des comptes
reconnaît que les collectivités ont fait
un effort de gestion
un gros effort du quai qu'elles peuvent
continuer et que et peu ferme en continu
et non mais et peuvent évidemment tout
le monde on peut toujours faire sans
tuer févr simplement simplement pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a un sentiment d'injustice
la même cour des comptes a reconnu que
en 2007 l'essentiel de la réduction du
déficit c'était les collectivités pour
50% s'était pas l'état or les
collectivités ne sont responsables que
de 10% de la dette de l'état et l'état
de beaucoup beaucoup plus
donc ce que l'on dit nous les
collectivités on est prêts à faire un
pas mais de grâce que l'état aussi se
serrer un peu la ceinture et je
remarquais tout à l'heure que le déficit
de l'état allait augmenter dans le
budget qu'on va nous présenter de plus
de 6,4 milliards d'euros à l'état de
faire un effort aussi voilà cette
question de justice en tous les cas le
premier ministre va tenter d'apaiser à
cette grogne des collectivités locales
il reçoit les responsables d'ailleurs
tous deux au rang 1 des collectivités
les régions les départements les villes
de france et il dit quand même qu'il ya
un peu de mauvaise foi dans cette grogne
est ce que vous reconnaissez vous avouer
un peu de mauvaise foi de votre part
écoutez et vit au sénat 17 juillet et
vivrait en disant voilà mes chers amis
on va faire les choses ensemble vers une
grande conférence territoriale et après
coup on a appris un train de mesures un
train de mesures justement qui
supprimait dans notre dos voilà qui
supprime un certain nombre de ressources
qui prenait des positions et il a même
dit ce jour là il a eu un propos
malheureux en disant moi il ya trop
d'élus
grosso modo les élus sont sont inutiles
alors que 90% sont totalement bénévoles
celle ci vise c'est une faille lui et
moi je vais pas lui dire qu'il serait de
mauvaise foi en tout cas il a du mal
avec la france territoriales mais je
veux lui dire que voilà au delà du
périphérique ya quand même une france
propre merci ben on aurait quand même
merci michael merci à tous bon soir à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]